I wanted to add a little personal note to the top of show.
I'm someone who puts a tremendous amount
of pressure on myself, and that is putting it so politely.
And like (growls).
And I live in that pressure cooker state.
And the other day, for some unknown to me reason,
I thought, can you think about the things that you've done,
rather than you need to do.
And I took some inventory, and so I thought as an exercise
as we make all of our to-do lists,
try to maybe make a have-done list as well.
And I see people nodding their heads in the wall
and I can't tell you what a sense of community
I feel right now, so thank you for this moment.
It means a lot to me.
And of course, as soon as I had it I thought,
well, what do I do with it?
Let's share it, all right.
(audience clapping)
Now, ironically, I would like to introduce you to someone
who already has a have-done list at her age
that is so incredibly impressive, it blows my mind, okay?
Imagine setting out to feed the hungry, shelter the homeless
and help those who are less fortunate
at just seven years old.
And now, at age 14, double the number, Sanya Pirani
from Minneapolis, Minnesota has created the organization
"Sanya's Hope For Children" in order to help young people
get the supplies they need, to succeed.
So, without further ado, and everything aside,
can we please welcome Sonya!
(audience clapping)
Hello, and may I ask, will you explain
what "Sanya's Hope For Children" is?
Well, "Sanya's Hope For Children" is a 501(c)(3)
student-lead, non-profit founded in 2017, January
and we're focused on children helping children
and our mission is that we strongly believe
that every child deserves basic human rights.
Like food, shelter, clothes, safety and education.
You are just incredible.
Will you please tell us about the latest project
that you are working on, I believe it's
collecting toys for homeless children.
Yeah, so this project is called
our "Christmas Bag Project" and we take volunteers,
my own Santa's Helper children team and myself,
we all sew these bags, and then we have donations
of school supplies, toys and books,
which are then put into the bags during an event
and then for this year, they will be delivered
to homeless shelters around Minnesota.
Well, we'd like to help.
We're gonna donate $10,000 to "Sanya's Hope For Children"
to help you continue the amazing work that you do.
Oh my God, that's so amazing!
I really appreciate it, thank you so much.
That is, oh my God.
Thank you for setting an example for us all
and we're gonna have your organization up on our website.
You're just incredible;
I'm so honored that you came on the show.
Well, I am so glad to have this opportunity
to come on the show, meeting with you has been so amazing.
I am so appreciative of you, thank you so much.
Well, right back at you, thank you Sanya, thank you.
We'll see you soon and check back in with you.
(upbeat music)